Dans la comédie musicale "Pal Joey",
Kim retrouve Sinatra
et fait jeu égal
avec la grande Rita Hayworth.
Puis, elle obtient le rôle de sa vie
dans "Vertigo",
devant la caméra d'Alfred Hitchcock.
- Je vais mourir.
Elle a dit que j'allais mourir.
Ne m'abandonne pas.
- Qu'est-ce qui les attirait
et les éloignait l'un de l'autre ?
- Hitchcock se comporta avec moi
comme un vrai gentleman.
Mais sans doute n'étais-je pas
son type de femme.
Personne ne savait
ce qui se cachait derrière son éternel sourire.
Le scénario baigne pourtant dans ce même climat
de romantisme vénéneux et obsessionnel
qui caractérise les meilleurs films noirs
d'Otto Preminger.
Mais si les préoccupations d'Hitchcock pouvaient
parfois rejoindre celles de l'Autrichien,
leurs méthodes de travail avec les acteurs
n'avaient que peu de points communs.
- En 1959, je signe un remarquable
drame judiciaire dans "Autopsie d'un meurtre",
où James Stewart horrifia les bien-pensants
en exhibant une petite culotte devant un tribunal.
Une fois encore,
le scandale déclenché par les censeurs
se retourna contre eux,
et le film fut un triomphe.
J'apparaissais même sur la bande-annonce,
preuve de la grande notoriété
dont je jouissais à Hollywood.
Au début des années 60,
je réalise plusieurs grosses productions
peu inspirées.
Après l'épopée de la naissance d'Israël
retracée dans "Exodus",
j'explore les caves du Vatican
dans une nouvelle superproduction
affichant un casting international,
"Le Cardinal".
Il faudra que je retourne
vers des productions
aux budgets et aux ambitions plus modestes
pour retrouver toute la vigueur
de mes chefs-d'œuvre des années 40 et 50.
Dans "Harry Sundown",
je traite avec justesse du racisme
dans les États du Sud
et je me réconcilie avec les cinéphiles.
En 1980, je tourne mon dernier film,
et en 1986, je tire le rideau,
sans savoir réellement pourquoi
j'avais tant de mal à travailler avec les femmes.
Tant pis.
Mon œuvre parle maintenant pour moi.
- En 1964, je trouve un nouveau grand rôle,
celui de la gentille prostituée
dans "Kiss Me, Stupid", de Billy Wilder.
- Dis-moi, Polly, comment ça tient ?
- Avec de la colle.
L'échec commercial de ce film
va briser ma carrière.
Le vieil ennemi d'Otto Preminger,
la Légion catholique pour la décence,
a en effet ordonné le boycott total
de cette comédie,
jugée offensante
pour l'institution du mariage.
- Si c'est la femme,
que fait-elle avec le petit ami ?
- En fait, il pense...
Ou plutôt elle pense...
Vous feriez mieux d'aller le voir.
- Aller voir quoi ?
- Kiss me, stupid.
- Je fais un retour remarqué
devant les caméras en 1978,
dans "Le Miroir se brisa",
d'après Agatha Christie.
j'ai enfin trouvé la paix intérieure
qui me manquait.
Après mon travail avec Otto Preminger,
je n'ai plus jamais renié ce que j'étais,
préférant quitter ce monde
pour vivre en harmonie dans le mien.
Avec "Embrasse-moi, idiot" et "Vertigo",
"L'Homme au bras d'or" est le 3e chef-d'œuvre
qui entretiendra pour les cinéphiles
le souvenir de la beauté
et du talent de Kim Novak.
On ne saura sans doute pas
comment fut créé hors caméra
le personnage de Molly,
mais on n'oubliera jamais
le regard fragile et doux de Kim Novak,
filmé par la caméra
d'un Otto Preminger qui se cherche toujours.